as winter approaches and approaches fast
in some parts of the country families
can expect to pay more to heat their
homes than at any other time in the last
decade since just last year Americans
collectively collectively will pay
nearly 24 billion dollars billion with a
B more that's additional money just to
heat their homes that includes the cost
of natural gas of electricity of heating
oil and a propane Meg Oliver went to
Norwalk Connecticut to see how Rising
costs there are hitting people we're
just trying to stay warm
this room during the winter you really
couldn't sit in because it was so drafty
Drew Todd used to pay about two dollars
for a gallon of oil to heat his home in
Norwalk Connecticut where he lives with
his wife and two sons but due to
inflation the cost to fill his 100
gallon tank has more than doubled
honestly I think it's going to hit seven
bucks in my opinion and can you afford
that not really no I don't I I know what
the heck we're going to do if it gets
really cold this winter what's your plan
extra sweatshirts extra blankets after
losing his job in March Todd applied for
a state Grant to help pay his energy
bill how much longer can you keep this
up I don't know we're going to keep it
up as best as possible and do little
with less Nationwide families can expect
to pay nearly 18 percent more to heat
their homes this winter compared to last
year heating oil is up 25 percent and
natural gas up 31 costing homeowners
hundreds more Lorenzo Wyatt owns Home
Comfort practice which teaches people
how to reduce their energy costs why are
we seeing an increase in home heating
costs it's supply and demand
first and foremost you have a global
market for energy for oil natural gas
and then those costs have gone up
because there's shortages as winter
approaches Wyatt advises improving
insulation in the home keeping the
thermostat at 68 degrees closing the
fireplace damper removing window air
conditioners and keeping your drapes
closed think of the home as a home
envelope or like a big blanket okay and
so you want that blanket to be as thick
as possible because what you want to do
is you want to keep the heat inside
windows are all closed sealed for the
winter Todd is hoping small adjustments
will keep his family warm and his wallet
Fuller this winter I don't know whether
to cry or laugh or you have to laugh and
you have to cry at the same time it's an
interesting emotion frustrating very
beyond beyond non-frustrating because
you don't know when something else and
it's going to happen something else will
happen for CBS mornings I'm Meg Oliver
in Norwalk Connecticut